she been not it's impossible to break
free handy I met Scott make an actual
Scout yeah
man sings thanks yeah tonight's the
secret party right everybody except the
douchebags in the Necker chips will be
going this could be the night of our
lives
Karl the town's deserted look what the
bouncer he's gone we should stick in
dude there's like nobody here this is
[__] awesome it's something wrong
with it we're gonna chess so let's make
up dummy John go face
wait through the stripper cocktail
waitress
what are you going on [__] you think I
was eating each other like a any more
questions
okay
everything's under control
tonight very sure what being a real
scouts all about we're just gonna stand
here I'm gonna go save the world
oh yeah dude it's going to Rogers he
looks like [__] they set him on fire
we tried to eat me
all right Scouts let's kick some zombie
ass
I got soup I don't think they were real
this bill is in history by